merci d'être avec nous Mélanie Vogel et
de nous accompagner pendant cette
première devenir sénatrice représentant
les Français établis hors de France
vêtements du groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire on a beaucoup
d'actualités à voir avec vous on
commence par le Qatar est d'abord la
Coupe du monde avant de parler du
Parlement européen est-ce que vous
comprenez qu'Emmanuel Macron se rendent
au Qatar mercredi pour soutenir les
Bleus lors de la demi-finale France
Maroc j'ai un peu du mal alors
évidemment le fait que les supporters
des équipes de foot regardent le foot
bon ça je le comprends moi je regarde
pas mais je comprends très bien que
voilà est-ce que vous boycotez ou parce
que vous regardez pas en général pour
être honnête je boycotte mais c'est pas
que ça me demande un effort très très
grand j'avoue de pas être bref mais non
le Emmanuel Macron qui s'y rend c'est
une caution présidentielle c'est un
symbole important et
c'est encore plus
étonnant le lendemain d'une affaire
aussi grave où on a le Qatar qui
s'imisse au plus haut de notre
démocratie européenne dans une affaire
de corruption vous en avez parlé tout à
l'heure qui est absolument gravissime
avec des valises de billets ou pour
payer des députés européens pour valider
des amendements dans leur on leur faveur
et c'est validé ça c'est validé le
l'ingérence gravissime d'un État tiers
au cœur de notre démocratie on va
revenir sur un parlementaire mais ça
veut dire qu'il n'aurait pas du sérum
pour vous au Qatar est-ce qu'il doit s'y
rendre en passant des messages
politiques avec une parole fort
qu'est-ce qui va faire est-ce que alors
s'il s'y rend que au moins il passe des
messages à la fois sur les droits des
personnel LGBT sur les droits des femmes
sur le droit du travail mais aussi sur
le l'influence du Qatar dans le monde et
sur le enfin si tu n'as à faire de
corruption extrêmement grave on peut pas
tolérer on peut pas aller en tant que
chef d'état d'un des plus grands pays
européens se rendre au Qatar deux jours
après ce qui se convient de découvrir
qui en fait une histoire qui remonte à
plusieurs années donc c'est quelque
chose de enfin de c'est une lame de fond
de l'influence du Qatar sur sur l'Union
européenne
et si Emmanuel Macron ne dit rien enfin
quel message on envoie aussi où vous
attendez une parole forte de sa part sur
la corruption et sur les droits humains
ou un message un peu plus subliminal
j'allais dire on a vu Amélie ou des
accastéral la ministre des Sports
arborer un t-shirt avec des manches
arc-en-ciel lors du quart de finale
contre l'Angleterre vous avez applaudi
ce geste je l'avais moi-même interpellé
en lui demandant de le faire donc
évidemment je vais pas m'attrister du
fait qu'elle les fait oui c'est bien
venue je trouve que c'est le minimum
mais bien sûr c'est bien sur le
Parlement européen justement alors vous
avez déjà donné un petit peu votre
réaction on rappelle que la
vice-président du Parlement a été arrêté
pour une affaire de corruption présumée
en lien avec le
Qatar alors évidemment vous nous avez
donné votre ex mais maintenant comment
on fait comment on empêche ce type de
pratique selon vous alors c'est vrai que
on a souvent tendance à penser que ces
affaires de valise avec des billets
c'est un peu
[Musique]
c'est pas en Europe ou alors c'était il
y a très longtemps en réalité on voit
que ça se passe au cœur du européen y
compris je veux dire là on est quand
même sur une affaire qui concerne une
résolution du Parlement européen qui est
un acte non contraignant on s'imagine
enfin on a peur de s'imaginer l'ampleur
du phénomène pour des décisions qui sont
vraiment importantes c'est à dire que là
on découvre à mon avis un petit bout de
la faire vous pensez qu'il y a d'autres
choses derrière si ils sont capables de
faire ça là on a découvert un million de
cash pour une affaire qui est
l'affaire du symbolique à une résolution
du Parlement européen qui condamne les
droits humains sur le catarbon alors
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont prêts à faire sur
des choses qui sont voilà
nous on avait moi je regarde avec un
encore plus d'amertume aujourd'hui
j'étais quand je travaillais au
Parlement européen j'étais en charge des
négociations comme concert politique sur
le l'encadrement des lobbys et on avait
proposé comme écologiste dans le cadre
les activités de lobbying des États
tiers parce que à l'époque on était très
inquiet notamment sur le rôle que jouer
l'Arabie Saoudite et la manière dont ils
exercent leur influence via des
compagnies privées qui se faisaient
passer pour des lobbystes etc et à
l'époque le groupe socialiste était
totalement opposé au fait qu'on contrôle
mieux ces activités j'avoue que je
repense depuis deux jours à ses
négociations et je me dis voilà
l'ampleur du phénomène m'inquiète
beaucoup et ça vous a surpris ou vous
n'avez pas été plus surprises je pense
que comme tout le monde on a quand même
été subjugué par le par Sam surprend pas
et que le Qatar essaie d'influencer les
votes au Parlement européen mais c'est
vrai que avoir au-delà du lobby et oui
là c'est de la corruption on s'est
criminel c'est pas du abusif c'est c'est
une organisation criminelle c'est des
valises de billets c'est la
vice-présidente socialiste du Parlement
européen qui est et c'est une situation
qui a mené l'ensemble à part les
Français l'ensemble du groupe socialiste
au Parlement européen a voté contre la
mise à l'ordre du jour d'une résolution
sur le Qatar donc c'est quand même
quelque chose qui a profondément
infiltré ce qui est le Parlement de tous
les Européens c'est quand même
extrêmement grave donc non j'étais pas
si j'étais quand même un petit peu
choqué j'avoue on va parler de ce qui se
passe au Sénat puisque nous avons nous
sommes beaucoup en tout cas avoir reçu
sur nos téléphones ces fameux SMS
concernant le compte personnel de
formation ce serait bientôt fini puisque
le Sénat a voté un texte en ce sens où
on en parle avec notre journaliste
parlementaire Alex tout ça
[Musique]
donc une proposition de loi pour
interdire le démarchage commercial
concernant le compte professionnel de
formation
CSMS intrusif qui nous propose
d'utiliser notre compte personnel de
formation c'est bientôt l'histoire
ancienne alors on va d'abord rappeler ce
que c'est le compte personnel de
formation c'est une somme d'argent dont
tout travailleur au demandeur d'emploi a
bénéficient tout au long de sa carrière
pour suivre une formation et ce CPF se
compte personnel de formation et bien
elle a beaucoup de succès ces dernières
années en 2019 grâce au CPF à 500 000
formations ont été financées la barre du
million a été dépassée en 2020 et on a
atteint plus de 2,1 millions de
formations en 2021 le problème c'est
qu'avec ce succès et bien il y a
beaucoup de démarchage commerciaux
d'organismes de formation qui
sollicitent les Français et parmi ces
démarchage il y a des dérives des
arnaques on va écouter sur ce sujet la
ministre en charge de l'enseignement
professionnel Carole Grandjean c'est
dérives consistent souvent à forcer les
individus à acheter des formations
ou de manière insuffisamment réfléchie
cela s'est traduit par des appels des
SMS ou des courriels en tant pestif de
la part de centre d'appel ou
d'organismes de formation ces arnaques
véhiculées bien souvent des informations
erronées sur les droits de l'individu et
sur l'objectif réel poursuivi par
l'organisme le préjudice financier lié
aux pratiques abusives et frauduleuses
est évaluée à 43 millions d'euros en
2021 une somme qui a été multipliée par
5 en un an pour mettre fin à ces
arnaques le Sénat donc adopté une
proposition de loi venue de l'Assemblée
nationale qui prévoit tout simplement
d'interdire le démarchage commercial
autour du compte personnel de formation
des enquêtes administratives seront
effectuées et en cas d'abus des amendes
sont prévues 75000 euros d'amende pour
une personne physique 375000 euros pour
une entreprise une proposition de loi
qui a été votée à l'unanimité par les
sénateurs et qui devrait être appliqués
au début de l'année prochaine mais la
niveau gel ce texte il va véritablement
protéger les Français contre toutes ces
incitation sur le compte personnel de
formation oui et nous nous l'avons voté
j'espère que ça va fonctionner après ce
qu'on avait proposé parce que les
arnaques et le démarchage commercial non
consenti le fait que on vous envoie des
SMS à vous n'avez rien demandé ben ça
concerne le compte personnel de
formation mais pas seulement nous ce que
nous avions proposé c'était d'adopter un
système comme le fond d'autres pays
européens un système où on doit
consentir explicitement à recevoir des
messages publicitaires et si on consend
pas et bien on n'a pas le droit de vous
les envoyer et parce que vous savez on a
on a interdit le démarchage pour les
rénovations des chaudières puis les
assurances puis le CPF en réalité c'est
un phénomène global le démarchage
commercial non consenti la régulation
des données personnelles parce que c'est
une faille dans le règlement donné
personnelle les appels téléphoniques et
la publicité en général et donc moi je
m'en félicite c'est très bien je fais
partie des gens j'ai même pas de CPF
mais avoir reçu beaucoup de message mais
je pense qu'on aurait pu avoir une
vision un peu plus globale de façon
générale sur le démarchage commercial
non consenti qui polluent la vie des
millions de Français qu'est-ce qui
explique toute ces arnaques toutes ces
sollicitations c'est aussi le succès la
pas du gain financier pour certains
organismes avec ce compte personnel de
formation oui c'est à dire il y a eu
d'abord il y a cette faille dans le ce
qu'on appelle le règlement rgpd ou les
mails etc mais le téléphone ça fait
partie voilà c'est une faille que qu'il
faut à mon avis réparer une autre chose
qui expliquée cette dérive c'est le
passage de de la délivrance en heure à
la délivrance en euros donc on a
monétisé le CPF au lieu d'avoir des
heures c'est devenu de l'argent et donc
ça a été plus facile de d'avoir ces
arnaques et puis faut le dire aussi un
contrôle
largement insuffisant de la de la
qualité des formations qui sont mises
sur la plateforme en ligne avec beaucoup
de d'arnaques de formation qui ne sont
pas vraiment des formations qualifiantes
qui sont pas vraiment qui sont des
arnaques voilà qui sont mal contrôlés
alors justement pardon avec je vous
redonne la parole mais justement parce
qu'on parle d'argent il y a un
amendement qui a été déposé au budget ce
weekend à l'Assemblée déposé par la
majorité présidentielle qui prévoit la
mise en place d'un ticket modérateur
pour les salariés qui se lancent dans
une formation ça veut dire que désormais
il y aura un reste à charge pour les
salariés sauf pour les demandeurs
d'emploi qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
cet amendement franchement je me demande
à quel moment le gouvernement va
s'arrêter de d'attaquer des droits comme
ça le droit à la forme en fait ça veut
dire que les salariés vont devoir payer
pour accéder à un droit la formation
d'abord c'est un droit individuel et
c'est quelque chose qui fait enfin avoir
des individus qui peuvent se former tout
au long de la vie et pas seulement avec
l'accord de leur employeur parce que ce
que ce que nous dit cet amendement là
c'est que si le vote employeur est
d'accord vous n'aurez pas à payer si
votre employeur n'est pas d'accord donc
si vous souhaitez vous former sur
quelque chose qui n'arrange pas votre
employeur vous devrez payer
la société vers laquelle on veut aller
c'est une société où les gens peuvent se
former à d'autres choses on a énormément
besoin de formation pour faire toute la
transition écologique de notre société
et je veux dire
la logique à quel besoin ça répond quel
besoin on a aujourd'hui de faire payer
les gens pour accéder à un droit à la
formation alors qu'on a besoin que les
gens se forment donc les gens se
formeront certainement moins puisqu'ils
devront payer franchement je ça va à
l'inverse de tout ce qu'il faut faire à
mon avis donc selon vous il faut
orienter ces formations vers tous les
domaines de la connaissance et pas
seulement vers le domaine économique
sous certains secteurs manquent
également d'emploi pourvu oui je pense
qu'il faut alors bien sûr qu'il faut
aussi avoir des formations qui sont qui
sont vraiment professionnalisantes et
qui s'inscrivent dans un chemin de
carrière professionnelle mais je pense
qu'il faut aussi valoriser les
formations qui participent de manière
générale avoir des personnes qui
s'ouvrent au monde qui découvrent de
nouvelles choses parce que ça fait
partie de ce qu'est une démocratie qui
fonctionne mieux et globalement avec ce
compte personnel de formation qui envoie
du succès ces dernières années on a
quand même franchi un cap dans la
formation de nos concitoyens
ouais je pense après encore une fois je
crois qu'il faut surtout améliorer la
qualité des formations qui sont fournies
parce que là on a un peu un peu
n'importe qui peut inscrire une
formation et vous faire payer de
l'argent pour voilà donc il faut
améliorer la qualité de ce qui est
fourni et
bon éviter les froids évidemment mais
moi je enfin la formation tout au long
de la vie c'est c'est un des c'est une
des choses à laquelle on reconnaît une
démocratie qui fonctionne bien et une
société qui s'élève
merci Alex à tout à l'heure évidemment
dans le club on parlera des républicains
d'abord on va voir l'actualité dans nos
régions mais la nuit vosgel grâce à nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
Rouen on retrouve Thierry Rabier bonjour
Thierry merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
vous êtes le rédacteur en chef de Paris
Normandie vous allez nous parler de
Bruno Le Maire puisqu'il était du côté
de chez vous à la centrale de pan-libre
vendredi sur le site justement de cette
centrale
exactement on avait même titre que Bruno
Le Maire était le VRP de luxe de DS il
est venu avec le patron de DF qui ne
pouvait pas rêver d'un meilleur
ambassadeur en plein débat national
public sur l'avenir du nucléaire en
France et donc le ministre est venu
réaffirmer pendant toute une matinée à
Paris près de Dieppe l'importance en
fait de la filière nucléaire en France
et même son caractère indispensable donc
sur le site que EDF a choisi pour
construire des prochains repères on peut
dire que ministériel du ministre de
l'économie tombé à pic pour EDF qui
aujourd'hui continue son travail sur ce
site pour implanter les nouveaux le
réacteur nucléaire de demain
vous avez une question pour mes
nouvelles
oui justement une question deux ans une
vous êtes la sénatrice des Français
d'étrangers vu de l'étranger comment
comment justement vous voyez justement
ce projet
gouvernemental de poursuivre la filière
nucléaire en France et par rapport à
votre appartenance au groupe Écologie
Les Verts on a le sentiment ici en
Normandie finalement que les opposants à
ce projet là se font peu entendre sont
très discrets sur la question et donc
voilà cette double question comment vous
voyez vous madame la sénatrice ce mix
énergétique que défend la majorité
présidentielle
merci alors je vous remercie de me poser
la question sur comment on voit ça de
l'étranger parce que de l'étranger en
tout cas même juste au niveau européen
le choix politique de la France non pas
de sortir lentement du nucléaire mais de
réentrer dans le pire de réinvestir de
nouveau dans des infrastructures
nucléaires il est pour beaucoup le pays
totalement incompréhensible j'ai été la
semaine dernière au Danemark il y avait
le Congrès du Parti vert européen au
Danemark ils sont en train de mettre en
place des tests pour des éoliennes de
450 mètres le vélo éolienne test qui
fait 271 m produit une seule éolienne de
quoi remplir les besoins de 18000 foyers
et pour eux c'est enfin les
renouvelables c'est le marché qui
fonctionne qui est des carbonées qui est
sûr qui est peu cher et qui fait
progresser leur société et c'est
incompréhensible de voir la France qui a
un potentiel d'énergie renouvelable
immense de savoir qu'on pourrait au
niveau européen en faisant les bons
investissements arriver dès 2040 à 100%
renouvelables de voir la France ce grand
pays au lieu de saisir cette opportunité
se relancer dans un chantier dont on
sait enfin le père de Flamanville c'est
20 milliards d'euros toujours pas 1 K
mais elles sont prévisibles l'énergie
éolienne et le solaire se sé prévisible
les prévisions météorologiques sont de
plus en plus fines on est capables de
savoir au niveau national et encore plus
au niveau européen si on a eu un
développement harmonieux des
renouvelables comment gérer les flux
d'énergie donc c'est pas intermittent on
a l'impression qu'il éolienne elle
s'arrête elle redémarre elle s'arrête
elle remarque c'est pas vrai une
éolienne c'est variable mais c'est
prévisible terrible vous avez un une
autre question là dessus vous avez eu
toutes vos réponses
[Musique]
sur le sujet ah écoutez en local je sais
pas mais en tout cas partout en France
nous sommes mobilisés on l'a montré au
niveau au Sénat à l'Assemblée nationale
sur le projet de loi pour développer les
énergies renouvelables pour faire
qu'enfin la France puisse enfin c'est
quand même dingue qu'on soit à qu'on est
de telles opportunités qu'on les
saisissent pas donc nous on est mobilisé
pour faire du projet de loi sur les
énergies renouvelables un véritable
outil d'accélération de l'investissement
dans les renouvelables et on sera tout à
fait mobilisé contre le projet de
développement du nucléaire parce que on
peut pas en fait c'est on peut pas
dépenser son argent deux fois donc on
peut pas à la fois investir pour
développer le nucléaire et investir pour
les renouvelables et à un moment donné
il faut choisir et notre choix il est
fait depuis longtemps c'est les
renouvelables parce que c'est sûr parce
que c'est décarboné parce que ça assure
notre indépendance énergétique pas comme
le nucléaire qui nous fait importer de
l’uranium de Russie et parce que ça crée
des emplois non délocalisables
merci Thierry merci bon là Thierry merci
Normandie aujourd'hui dans son édition
de Dieppe chantier UPR attention au
cadre de vie c'est à la Une de votre
journal merci beaucoup pierre d'avoir
été avec nous puisqu'on parle d'écologie
un mot sur ce qui s'est passé ce weekend
du côté de Marseille à Bouc-Bel-Air ou
des activistes écologistes ont mené une
action contre une cimenterie du groupe
Lafarge d'importants dégâts ont été
constatés l'usine est à l'arrêt à
l'emploi près de 200 personnes est-ce
que vous soutenez ce type d'action
moi je crois que la question aujourd'hui
c'est au-delà de savoir est-ce que moi
personnellement je soutiens ou pas ce
type d'action je pense que
quoi non pas quoi qu'on fasse justement
si on ne fait rien si on continue à
avoir des industries qui polluent
lourdement si on continue à avoir des
gouvernements qui prennent pas les
bonnes décisions pour les générations
futures les actions de désobéissance
civile
de plus en plus violente elles sont
inéluctables on a une jeunesse qui n'en
peut plus de voir qu'on a on connaît
parfaitement le problème on a toutes les
solutions sur la table et on a des
politiques qui n'agissent pas et des
entreprises qui font du greenwashing et
en fait cette jeunesse n'en peut plus et
si on ne fait rien c'est pas moi je
pourrais rien y faire les actions de ce
type elles vont se multiplier donc
l'urgence sans passer par la violence
par des dégradations moi je défends
jamais la violence il faut pas en passer
par la violence bon après c'est des
dégradations de bien voilà
mais ça fait partie des actions
malheureusement
militantes qui arrivent et moi en fait
en fait mon sujet c'est pas les
militants à Bouc-Bel-Air je sais pas si
vous voyez Bouc-Bel-Air c'est c'est
pollué à un stade on a un taux de cancer
bien plus élevé que dans le reste de la
France dans cette région là autour de
autour de fosses parce que c'est
extrêmement pollué et moi mon sujet
c'est pas les militants est-ce que c'est
la bonne action etc je pense que c'est
pas le débat qu'on doit avoir le débat
qu'on doit avoir c'est comment on fait
pour répondre aux besoins vitaux d'une
jeunesse qui voit tous les problèmes on
a lu toutes les études on a toutes les
solutions et qui voit qu'on ne règle pas
le problème et à un moment donné on peut
pas leur dire écoutez calmez-vous
arrêtez d'abîmer du ciment enfin c'est
leur vie qui est en jeu on va parler de
votre partie
a donc été élu ce week-end secrétaire
national d'Europe Écologie le vert et
dit notre ligne c'est l'écologie
indivisible c'est quoi l'écologie
indivisible
ce qu'elle veut dire c'est que
l'ambition des écologistes c'est
d'arriver à
agglomérer
autour de nous ce grand mouvement social
qui qui est né en France autour de
l'ambition de la transition écologique
du pays c'est pour ça que voilà on est
aujourd'hui dans une situation où certes
on n'a pas
on n'a pas fait le score à l'élection
présidentielle qu'on aurait espéré mais
les écologistes aujourd'hui c'est le
parti qui quand même je le rappelle mise
à part Paris et Marseille on est quand
même dans la majorité gouverne les
grandes villes de France c'est un
mouvement politique qui gouverne en huit
pays européens nous avons trois groupes
parlementaires le plus grand groupe
jamais au Parlement européen c'est un
mouvement qui est en qui est en
croissance on regarde souvent voilà le
score de l'élection présidentielle qui
est qui est certes je le nie pas mais
dans la grande Histoire
politique de notre pays et de l'Europe
c'est un mouvement qui doit pas me dire
qu'il doit agglomérer et qui doit se
transformer pour répondre pour faire
écho à ce besoin dans la santé qui passe
parce que c'est ça la question est-ce
que ça passe par Europe Écologie Les
Verts
sinon je serais pas chez europécologie
et vert si je pensais pas que ça passait
bien sûr le principal il y a il y a pas
eu énormément de votants pour votre
élection ce que dénonçait d'ailleurs
Sandrine Rousseau il demande du premier
tour est-ce que c'est un parti qui est
tentant de se refermer sur lui-même
c'est un parti qui est en train de se
refermer sur lui-même non pas vraiment
c'est un parti qui est pas encore arrivé
à s'ouvrir largement pour accueillir ce
qu'on appelle le peuple de l'écologie
c'est à dire les millions de personnes
qui votent pour les écologistes que ce
soit aux élections municipales aux
élections régionales aux élections
européennes qui veulent que ça marche
qu'on fasse l'écologie en France et
c'est vrai que nous on a beaucoup de
travail à faire et moi je fais partie
des gens qui l'ont toujours dit dans ce
parti pour on a beaucoup de travail à
faire s'ouvrir pour avoir un
fonctionnement qui voilà qui est plus
plus accueillant je crois que c'est
c'est ce que Marine tondeuillier veut
faire et c'est vrai qu'on doit réussir
ce Paris-là d'accueillir d'être la
réponse à cette ambition dans la société
c'est la bonne personne pour le faire
parce que sans vouloir lui faire offense
elle est pas très connu du grand public
mais non
c'est pas un peu une erreur de ne pas
parce que dans vos statues en fait un
élu national un parlementaire ne peut
pas postuler à la tête du parti est-ce
que ça c'est pas une erreur si vous
voulez ouvrir populariser et ramener des
gens est-ce qu'il faut pas des figures
un peu plus connus
c'est un débat qu'on peut avoir et que
je pense on va de toute façon avoir
parce que vous savez qu'on a lancé ce
grand chantier de la refondation voilà
avec les états généraux de l'écologie
qui doivent arriver à l'été c'est un
débat à avoir est-ce que cette règle
elle est elle est la meilleure ou pas
maintenant marine tondeuillier je pense
que là aujourd'hui oui c'était la
c'était la meilleure personne c'est
quelqu'un qui qui est travailleur qui
est déterminé qui a un sens du collectif
sans faille et je pense qu'elle a toutes
les qualités pour faire ce travail là
aujourd'hui la prochaine séance échéance
pardon ce sont les européennes est-ce
que vous avez envie d'être tête de liste
pour ces européennes pourquoi
je suis
co-présidente du Parti vert européen
donc c'est un peu une de mes
responsabilités j'ai été élu pour ça
pour porter le projet écologiste des
vers européens je le fais en France je
l'ai fait la semaine dernière au
Danemark je vais le faire dans pas
longtemps à Vienne je l'ai fait en
Espagne justement de le porter aux
élections européennes j'ai envie de
faire cette campagne oui bien sûr je
ferai la campagne je la ferai partout en
Europe et pas comme tête de liste
je vois pas pourquoi je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens qui sont tout à fait
capables d'être tête de liste jour que
je vois pas pourquoi il y aurait besoin
de d'avoir moi comme tête de liste il y
a des gens formidables qui pourront le
faire merci Mélanie au Jeanne aura
l'occasion d'en parler merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin dans
20 minutes dans le cadre des on ira à
Limoges puisque un rassemblement a lieu
ce matin donc devant la gare de Limoges
pour réclamer une meilleure desserte
entre le Limousin et Paris on va en
parler avec le rédacteur chef du
populaire du centre ce sera dans 20
minutes d'abord on accueille notre
prochaine invité c'est François Patriot